whatever I could have said no but this
is the best arson investigation training
program in the world Wallace hands down
a last minute opening like this is the
opportunity of a lifetime for severod
Chicago Fire addresses Taylor Kinney's
absence they have a way of keeping the
audience on their toes on Wednesday's
season 11 episode titled damage control
Taylor's character Lieutenant Kelly
Severide did not make an appearance but
his absence was felt by his wife Stella
at the top of the episode Stella is in
their Empty Apartment while he's off at
an arson investigation program in
Alabama I couldn't think of a better man
to recommend for the spot I hope you can
understand as ofi boss Van Meter
explained to Bowden who was upset that
he lost one of his best firefighters
with just one day's notice the last
minute opportunity was just too good to
pass up it doesn't mean he's planning a
transfer at ofi and I know it'll be a
burden on this house for a while but the
expertise Severide will bring back here
to 51 will benefit the whole department
back in
Source close to
closed and firmed T that Taylor Who's
led the NBC firefighter drama since its
debut in 2012 was taking a leave of
absence to deal with a personal matter I
love this show I love I love my gig I
love this gig and playing Kelly and
while the circumstances surrounding his
exit aren't clear the news came as a
shock if I wasn't doing what I'm doing I
could see myself being a firefighter
when I was a kid I always I always
looked up to those guys it's basically
Taylor Kenny is getting paid to play oh
yeah that's the yeah I'm kind of living
the dream the cast and crew were
reportedly informed of his departure the
day of with scripts being tweaked and
Rewritten to account for his absence the
tone of the show is it's you know it's a
drama and a lot of the time it's serious
so to break it up every everyone kind of
goes each other to laugh and that's what
we do I mean we're with each other more
than
most people are with their own families
well now we know how the writers handle
program server I got into very cool yeah
is I feel for kid long distance is no
fun true the uncertainty around Taylor's
future on the show comes amid major
changes in recent years for the one
Chicago Universe following Brian T's
Chicago Med send-off last year Jesse Lee
sofer's Chicago PD departure in 2022 and
Jesse Spencer's Chicago fire exit in
2021. Taylor told E.T having Jesse
Spencer back for the wedding episode was
a treat shot over 200 episodes with him
I missed the guy it was it was exciting
it's uh it's like getting the gang back
together and while it's unclear whether
Taylor's time away from the show is
permanent back in 2021 he told E.T he's
in it for the long haul it's just a good
group of people we really enjoy each
other's company and we love what we do
so hopefully we we keep uh keep being
able to do what we do and hopefully
people keep watching
[Music]
thank you